I'm heading back to the kitchen and to
make sure they don't mess up
concentration is incredible
two seconds come over guys I've got some
very positive news there may be a big
lead coming through with a major and I
mean major coffee stop there's a strong
possibility that we could go into
several stores cafe Nero but it means
you've got to get it consistent it's
gotta fit in the box it's got to look
perfect it's got a taste [ __ ] amazing
blow him away I think we can learn the
deal let's go guys
my remaining team now need to produce
that perfectly consistent batch of
slices Adonis has dropped a glass jug
the last thing we need now is a shard of
glass in the treacle mix that would sink
the slice before it's even made the
shelves you get one shot at this one
attempt so I'm gonna personally ice it
cut it absolutely 100% four centimeters
okay every turn done every time it has
to be consistent across the board right
fingers crossed
okay with a box of freshly baked slices
I'm heading straight to my meeting with
Kathy Nero
I'm basically the future the bad boy
bakery is in the box is in the box
head office is only five miles from the
prison in central London's common garden
hi good morning it's called Ramsey here
to see Paul thank you we're gonna
convince them to take this and hopefully
get captain EO to run with this Jesus
I'm incredibly nervous about today's
meeting with development director Paul
Edgington it's make-or-break time for
the bad boys bakery hello Paul Gordon
welcome thank you follow me if Paul says
no there's no plan B may I try please
please please please
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude consistency
hmm very interesting combination of
lemon and treacle with the biscuit base
mm-hmm does it work very nice it's good
it's very good
great
no I think I think our customers will
like that that's a great start
after all my kitchen team's hard work
it's a massive relief that Paul likes
the slice but does he like it enough to
place the order that keeps us in
business I think what we should do is we
should we should take maybe 10 or 11 of
our stores and showcase it hello
we do at least a week yeah and then
we'll know by the end of the week we
know Paul has decided to trial the slice
thank you I play yeah in around a dozen
cafes within a few miles at the prison
now it's down to the public if they buy
it we've got a chance of a much bigger
order that is great news
I'm so happy who'd have thought you know
a company that is one of the biggest in
the country now taking that little bar
from Brixton prison inside a freaking
prison who would have thought Daria it's
just like wow can the boys do it I mean
it's gonna be a hard to pull that off
we've got just 48 hours to manufacture
1,100 perfect slices bringing in golden
Ramsey